so desperately did not want to include  him in the trade to get Paul George and  after speaking with that young man it is  so clearly evident links tonight to  Milwaukee probably but those two things  you're thinking of defensively then a  Kubo a deep catch a quick turn bucket of  the fact beyond saves Burton can't hit  from the corner good Gallinari  not available tonight second half of  back-to-back  Ramsey nursery giannis off one-way pasta  the delivery from the Yanis identical  book of bucks 50 and age there's 26 and  3 at home thanks the playoffs by earlier  than any team in league history that man  a huge reason why and Milwaukee without  Chris Middleton the honest is 3 here is  good